yesterday I told you about one of the
most bata moments and by beta
I mean beta as opposed to alpha moments
of the trump presidency which was that
after Donald Trump invited Vladimir
Putin to the White House after the
Helsinki summit Putin turned it down and
it's truly the opposite of a Power Move
from Trump it's yet another humiliation
as I told you yesterday
this wasn't some maybe some day type of
invitation Trump even tweeted about it
last week it was very clear plans were
being made Trump saying the summit with
Russia was a great success except with
the real enemy of the people the fake
news media I look forward to our second
meeting so that we can start
implementing some of the many things
discussed including stopping terrorism
security for Israel nuclear
proliferation cyberattacks trade Ukraine
Middle East peace North Korea and more
there are many answers some easy and
some hard to these problems but they can
all be solved totally played by Putin
Putin says I'm not gonna do it Putin
looks like the powerful one he simply
can't be covered bothered to come to
Washington DC and now what is the Trump
White House do they retract the
invitation but wait a second Putin
already said he wasn't coming why is the
invitation being retracted great
question I have no idea could the White
House possibly look weaker than it looks
right now NSA National Security Advisor
John Bolton said in a statement
yesterday that this Trump Putin meeting
quote should take place after the Russia
witch hunt is over so we've agreed that
it will be after the first of the year
but Putin already said he's not coming
do you want to come to my birthday party
no I don't well I'm retracting your
invitation anyway so you can't come to
it this was called we knew this would
happen and it happened I also didn't
know that the Russia investigation was
going to be over with by the end of the
year yeah it was gonna be over with by
the end of last year and now it's going
to be over with
by the end of this year it's the George
Costanza presidency or the Larry David
presidency I don't know which is a
better a better term for it this is the
same thing Trump did with some sports
teams I don't remember now if it was
like the Philadelphia Eagles the Golden
State Warriors maybe it was both and
when they the players
it's saying we're not gonna go to the
White House for this meet and greet
Trump cancelled the invitation or the
event altogether and instead had like a
flag rally or something like that if
there's any way to sum up in total the
presidency of Trump in terms of its
style it's the bully who isn't even
popular or powerful enough to be a bully
people just ignore him like he would be
a bully if anybody paid attention but
instead he's just ignored and I've been
reading more and more about the daddy
issues with Trump and you mentioned this
yesterday I did Trump had this
relationship with his father
where his dad was neglectful and Trump
constantly wanted to impress his dad so
in comes Putin Putin skilled at
manipulation in the exact same way that
he ends up being a sort of father-type
figure to trump the better statesmen the
smarter guy the much richer guy by the
way and if you look at a video of Trump
and Putin in Helsinki that is the
relationship that is telegraphed by the
dynamic where Trump doesn't want to
upset Putin he wants to be seen with
respect he wants to please Putin in the
may way that maybe he was never able to
please his dad and if it weren't for the
geopolitical and national damage that it
was doing it would merely be a sad story
of a father and sons relationship gone
bad but here Trump's daddy issues are
actually leading to massive massive
repercussions today's program was made
possible in part by Blink esteem /
Pakman I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
studs is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books if they condense them
into 15 minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by
new bling cast calm / Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up